so Xena Bosch is the assistant to Brett
Kavanaugh who allegedly threw up a white
power symbol I actually know the other
day she was sitting like this
demonstrated I can't even I mean there
you go
they I can get in the camera now some
weird way of sitting that gave the white
power gesture now there was all over
Twitter social media didn't really hit
the news so much because people
dismissed it as that's nothing you guys
are being ridiculous well this is what
she did yesterday and I'm gonna bring
the tweet up on the screen from a guy
named Karl Newman I don't even know what
this guy is but it was a useful tweet
and so anyway he said what the hell is
wrong was he in a bash and there she is
in just throwing it up and if you watch
the video she really just throws it up
for no reason at all it's almost like
she pretended to talk to somebody and
then threw it up I don't really keep I
don't care outside of the context of of
a video that I've done I did previously
and while I was at David's to do so I
want to play this video where I
explained that it really doesn't matter
if they are simply trolling the way you
use a symbol the origins of a symbol and
its usage really decide whether or not
it becomes a symbol of hate and and as
we can see in this video that while
they're trying to make this a gag the
fact of the matter is is that the gag
originated in white supremacist 4chan
channels and spread and continuously is
now being used by people who are
demonstrating hate and so I explained it
much better about a year ago in regards
to a case of Cassandra Fairbanks who is
a right-wing troll she was at she's
she's everywhere now so I don't have to
explain that but she's suing a reporter
about claiming that she was using a
white supremacist symbol enough with the
introduction here's the video from last
year about this at David's to do
Cassandra Fairbanks she writes for big
league politics she's written for quite
a few other outlets
she has a big voice on Twitter she was
once a Bernie Sanders a fervent Bernie
Sanders supporter and that's where I
first met her and got connected with her
and she quickly devolved into being
strongly affiliated with white
nationalist white supremacist definitely
affiliated with the alt-right people
like Richard Spencer she quickly
devolved from being a Bernie Sanders
supporter to be an all-out Trump girl
overnight that's a whole different
conversation
Cassandra Fairbanks is zooming suing a
fusion reporter Elma roller because she
believes that Emma defamed her when she
tweeted an image of Fairbanks at the
White House making what ilma roller from
fusion claimed to be a white power hand
gesture in the picture behind us you see
she's there with Mike Stern of itch
however you pronounce his last name and
so this is what the lawsuit is basically
saying that Emma by tweeting this out it
was retweeted I believe six thousand
times by tweeting this out and saying
that this was a white supremacist hand
gesture that she's slandered and defamed
Cassandra Fairbanks I don't know how you
defame anyway I'll leave all the ad
homonyms for the end so here's where
this is going to actually be this is
going to be an extra interesting lawsuit
for several reasons and for reasons that
I don't think Cassandra has thought out
all the way and so I'm gonna help you
think it out Cassandra the question
behind this is what's in a symbol what
defines a symbol what gives a symbol its
meaning because and the reason I start
there's not just to be philosophical
it's really because this symbol this
okay symbol right it started off as a
joke in alright circles and fortune and
and in that entire cesspool it started
off as a means of trolling the media and
they wanted to see that if they could
get
personalities and media heads and
journalists to say that a symbol that is
rather innocuous is now a symbol of
white supremacy and because they see
this as a big joke there is they can
easily claim plausible deniability
whenever using it in the context like in
the picture behind me they can say oh
this is not a white nationalist symbol
because we're just making a joke at ha
ha hee hee you fell for the joke and so
now here she's suing Cassandra Fairbanks
is suing Elma roller and she's saying
I'm not a white nationalist
you're sullying my brand I don't really
know how the hell you're gonna sell your
brand but by calling her a white
nationalist when she affiliates herself
in every single tweet every single day
of the week with the most disgusting
scum of the white nationalist movement
like why do you want to run away from
this now this is this is let's go off on
a tangent Cassandra why would you want
to run away from what you embrace all
day long and apparently it's because she
wants to make a statement I don't think
this is going to make the statement that
she thinks it's going to make because
now we come full circle and ask
ourselves what gives a symbol meaning
and this is a question that the judge is
going to have to decide I said on a
video last week that it doesn't really
matter what they call themselves it
doesn't matter how they self-identify
what matters is who they are and what
they're doing with that identification
right and so if whether or not they call
themselves white nationalists is
irrelevant whether or not they
self-identify as white supremacist it's
completely irrelevant if everything that
they do is consistent with white
supremacy it doesn't matter if you don't
call yourself a Nazi if you espouse Nazi
rhetoric if you are now a spouse Nazi
ideologies if you use the symbol and the
gestures and the and the salutes of
Nazism it doesn't matter if you don't
call yourself a Nazi what matters is who
you are and what you're doing with it
and what they're doing with
the symbols is identifying these rather
innocuous symbols with white supremacy
and with white nationalism and with
Nazism over and above what they're doing
with it it also has a connection with
who started this and where did it come
from and who's the leading force behind
it and some of the leading forces behind
this symbol really is a Nazi a stuff
about well he wouldn't consider himself
to be a true Nazi but Richard Spencer
one of the most hate-filled nationally
recognized scumbags of white nationalism
and so he's a part of the of the of the
beginnings of this symbol this is where
it had a start this is where it had his
inception it had his inception as a joke
but it was a jump started by a bunch of
white nationalists and the way that it's
utilized in the way that it's carried
out in society and society is kind of a
broad term the way is carried out in
their circles is while they're
simultaneously making a joke of it they
are utilizing it as a way of identifying
people who carry the same filthy white
nationalist ideologies so the question
that the judge is going to have to
answer is what's in the meaning of what
gives a symbol its meeting what what
gives a symbol what imbues a symbol with
the hatred that surrounds it what causes
that because it's not as though then not
to the swastika by by just by the shape
itself is naturally an evil symbol but
it has most certainly become a symbol of
evil in society because of who used it
and how it was used and so well this
symbol this this okay symbol is rather
innocuous and it's something rather
bland and mundane who's using it and how
are they using it I would be interested
in seeing how the judge will decide on
this because the implications
have far-reaching ramifications if he
does make the state make the case that
it will it doesn't matter how this
started what matters is where it came
from and how it's being utilized then
now we will actually have on court
record a decision a case a case study
saying that this symbol that the 4chan
trolls and Richard Spencer's of the
world started off as a way of trolling
the media now is itself a symbol of
white supremacy and everyone who's
holding it up and using it will now be
forever affiliated with a symbol of
white supremacy Nazism and all-around
hatred so while this is an attack on
Emma roller and I'm quite sure there's
going to be a lot of us who gonna you
know help her with her legal fees if
necessary I'm sure her organization
probably has lawyers ready for it while
this is the direct attack on Emma and
while this is something that Cassandra
Fairbanks thinks is going to make a
statement in her favor it's very likely
that this is going to be turned around
on her and forever stigmatize her with
the reality that she went into the White
House briefing room and use a symbol
that she felt was trolling America but
because of where it started and how it's
been used is quite and actually a symbol
of white supremacy and white nationalism